دعونا الان نذهب معكم الى جديد التطورات
الاوكرانيه الروسيه اذا ما تحدثنا عن جبهه
بخمه ام المعارك فخ بخمط انزلقت اليه
روسيا وفق مخطط اوكراني مدروس بعنايه وفق
صحيفه وولز دعونا اذا نبدا معكم في هذه
الخريطه لنشرح اكثر ونذهب من بخمت نذهب
ونشرح اكثر طبيعه هذه المعارك وهذه
المعركه الممتده منذ اشهر دون حسم لاي من
الطرفين سواء من روسيا اوكرانيا فما الذي
فعلته كييف بالتحديد في هذه المنطقه التي
تقع شرق اوكرانيا بالتحديد كيف بدات اذا
تستنزف قدرات الدفاع الروسيه باصرار عن
بخمه في معركه استمرت عشره اشهر مثلا
عمليات الاستنزاف كانت بمحاصره في
الدبابات التي وصلت طبعا للقوات
الاوكرانيه من مختلف الدول الحلفاء التي
تعتبرها اوكرانيا والتي كانت قدمت لها
ايضا تعرضت عده منا في ضخمه لقصف كما ايضا
في عده مناطق استراتيجيه هناك تعويل كثير
على هذه المنطقه لانه سيكون هناك نقطه
امداد من هذه المنطقه الى المناطق الاخرى
وبالتالي ايضا تعتبر كافه الاطراف بان
السيطره على بخمه هي سيطره معنويه رمزيه
لكل من الطرفين رغم انها لم تحسم بعد اذا
قاده اوكرانيون اكدوا بان التطورات
الاخيره اثبتت نجاح استراتيجيته المتمثله
بالتمسك بالمدينه لاطول فتره ممكنه طبعا
كان في هناك اذا سيطر وثبات حوالي هذه
المنطقه بالنسبه لبخموت اذا تحدثنا عن
التمسك في المدينه طبعا هذا التمسك في
المدينه تمثل
بالسيطره على بعض الكيلومترات كما اعلنت
الجهات الاوكرانيه والتحدث ايضا عن الصمود
من قبل بعض القوات الاوكرانيه في المناطق
المتعدده في هذه المنطقه بالتحديد كان
هناك اذا عمليه وطبعا بطبيعه الحال عمليات
الاستنزاف والمعارك هي تستنزف الجهه
الروسيه وتستنزف الجهتين سواء من حيث
العتاد والعتيد يريد القاده الروس
الاستيلاء على بخمه لاسباب عسكريه ايضا
يامنون ان تشكل المدينه منصه انطلاق نحو
المزيد من المكاسب الميدانيه الهدف اذا
كان الاشتباك واستنفاذ عتاد وعتيد القوات
الروسيه في هذه المنطقه بالتحديد طبعا
منطقه بخموت كان فيها اشتباكات مستمره
لعده اشهر وحتى هذه النقطه اذا لم يحسم اي
من الطرفين هذه الجبهه المشتعله جدا في
شرق اوكرانيا والتي تريد ايضا روسيا
استكمال السيطره عليها رغم التضارب
الروايات والمعلومات المتعلقه في هذه
المنطقه بالتحديد طبعا نستكمل معكم جديد
الاخبار المتعلقه بهذه النقطه بالتحديد
حيث ان القوات الروسيه كانت تستعد لشن في
اماكن اخرى والتضارب الانباء طبعا في
الاسبوع الماضي شنت اوكرانيا هجمات مضاده
مفاجئه كانت مكنتها من استعاده عده
كيلومترات سواء في الضواحي الغربيه لهذه
المدينه طبعا هذه الهجمات والمكاسب
الاوكرانيه كانت خففت من قبضه روسيا على
طرق الامداد الحيويه كما دفعتها لارسال
وحدات اضافيه الى ضواحي المدينه
اعتقد انها لعبه ما لا اظن انها تطابق
الواقع انها تنسجم مع اهدافهم واعتقد ان
حكومتنا تمسك كل شيء قدر المستطاع تحت
السيطره وتفعل وستفعل كل شيء ممكن
هذا مزيف وغير ح قيقي
انا اعتقد انه خطا ما تم ارتكابه من حيث
تزويدهم بالذخيره ولكن الان تم تصحيحه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات